[Music]
let's talk Dancing with the Stars real
quick health he's hearing um Victoria
Val found themselves in jeopardy this
week but for her making it each week is
already a huge victory yeah it's
actually hard to wrap your head around
the fact that she's even succeeding
autumn - Oh Victoria still has no
feeling in her legs after being
paralyzed for ten years so with two
dances to perform on Monday where her
cells are all the more challenging so
it's kind of like driving a car
blindfolded with your hand off the
steering wheel the scariest thing for me
also is like they've heard legs starts
to spasm and then literally like goes
Exorcist valves also looking out for the
23 year old outside the ballroom you
want to we party together I haven't seen
this much cleavage in a while the
suitors coming after you it's been
interesting meanwhile Valley is happily
partnered up in real life with troupe
dancer Jenna Johnson but he's not quite
ready to put a ring on it I don't feel
the pressure I feel excited but I would
love to have kids you know I I can't
wait to be a father I was like thinking
it might be like a genival engagement at
Christmas cuz you know it's the holiday
season is when everyone gets engaged the
holiday season could just be sacred as
holidays okay and we'll have the
engagement party alright we'll see okay
keep me posted
okay okay great I love them together so
I hope it happens in 28
yeah can you imagine him doing the first
dance at his wedding he'll fantastic on
it
perfect okay
[Music]
you
[Music]